الثقل الاقتصادي المترتب على دول المحيطه
في السودان يبدا بعبئ اللاجئين لكنه يمر
حصرا ببوابه بحريه واسعه
بورتسودان احدى بوابات السودان الطبيعيه
الشرقيه على البحر الاحمر وتبعد عن
العاصمه الخرطوم
675 كيلو مترا يبلغ طول الساحل البحري
السوداني اكثر من
2200 كيلومتر ما يجعله واحدا من اطول
السواحل البحريه في العالم
ميناء بورتسودان افتتح منذ 114 عاما بسعه
مليون و300 الف حاويه سنويا ويعد الميناء
الرئيسي في السودان وواحدا من اكثر
الموانئ كفاءه في افريقيا ماذا هذه
هذا البورتسودان موانئ متخصصه بينها
الميناء الجنوبي وهو مخصص للحاويات ايضا
هناك الميناء الشمالي يستخدم كمنفذ رئيسي
لاستيراد السلع الاستراتيجيه مثل الوقود
والقمح والسكر هناك ايضا ميناء سواكن هذا
الميناء مخصص لنقل المسافرين وصادرات
الماشيه فيما ميناء بشائر ومخصص بعمليات
تصدير نفر دوله جنوب السودان ميناء
بورسودان منفذ لدول حبيسه اي تلك التي لا
تملك واجهه بحريه مثل اثيوبيا هو جنوب
السودان فاقتصاد جنوب السودان قائم بنسبه
95% على عائدات النفط واي عرقله او اغلاق
ستكون كارثيه على الطرفين حيث تصدر جوبا
170 الف برميل يوميا عبر خط انابيب يمر
بجارتها الشماليه اي منجبا لبورتسودان
وتستفيد الخرطوم في المقابل من تحصيل رسوم
عبور النفط والمقدره ب 300 مليون دولار
سنويا الميناء اصبح مؤخرا مركزا للتنافس
الدولي والاقليمي
كما زادت اهميته لحمايه امن البحر الاحمر
والذي يعبر منه نحو 20% من التجاره
العالميه و30% من تجاره النفط لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات